- They need to have this in the Olympics.
I would bring home gold.
- High five me.
(laughing)
(upbeat music)
- Today we're eating Oreo's.
- We're gonna put blind folds on
our face and put Oreo's in our mouth.
- I love an Oreo.
- Oreo's are not sacred, you
know, it's a starting ground.
We can play, let's have some fun.
- I'm interested that
we're gonna be blindfolded,
just because that's gonna
change the perception.
If I see an image of a birthday cake
and I have a birthday cake Oreo,
and my minds already going birthday cake
and it tastes like a birthday cake.
I don't see a birthday cake?
I don't know, maybe it
tastes like a radish.
(laughing)
- Alright, can't see a damn thing.
- Is it--
ew, ew, that's a little sour.
- It's like oh, so sour.
- Oh.
- Lemon.
- Yeah, I think you're right.
- I know what it is, it's Key Lime Pie.
- Is it Key Lime Pie?
(bell dinging)
- What?
- Wow, I am right?
- Wow, nice, high five.
Don't hit me in the face.
- Cheers.
- Mmm, no, mmm, no, try it.
- It's like a breakfast, is it a Poptart?
- It tastes like a Poptart
filling inside of an Oreo.
- Yes.
- Hold on, I just tasted something,
its some kind of pie now.
- It's blueberry.
It's blueberry muffin.
- Oh, what?
Is that an option?
- I don't know.
- It's strawberry
Poptart flavored.
- Strawberry.
- I know that's blueberry,
it's blueberry pie.
- You're right.
(bell dinging)
- [All] Woo.
- Yes.
- Wow, you're good.
- Blueberry pie?
- It's blueberry Poptart flavored.
- I'm not a fan of this one.
- Eww.
- Mmm
- Cocoa Puffs?
- Oh, it does taste like Cocoa Puffs.
- This is the O.G. Oreo.
I got it.
- Hold on, that's too easy.
- It's just chocolate.
- Chocolate.
- This is an uh oh Oreo, I believe.
Final answer.
(bell dinging)
- Yeah.
- The (bleep).
- What?
- I'm very shocked.
- Something very fruity.
- It smells like a cherry ICEE.
- This one smells insane.
- Maybe even like a
Twizzlers or a Red Vine.
- It has the consistency of toothpaste.
- If this isn't Twizzlers,
I'll pay you $100.
- You heard that internet.
- Oh my God, you know what it is?
You know what it is?
- Wait.
- I think I know what it is.
- That smells like a
God damned Swedish Fish.
- (Mumbles) dude.
- I think it's Swedish Fish.
(gasps)
Right?
- Is it Swedish Fish?
(bell dinging)
- Oh my God.
- Close.
- Oh yeah, you're real sad cause you're
about to get a hundred big ones.
(laughing)
- Eww.
- I knew it.
- I wasn't too mad at the blueberry.
- The blueberry one was interesting.
- The original, you know,
I'm not in to sequels.
You'd have to have a pretty damn
good sequel to Trump the first original.
- You need like Back
to the Future Part Two.
- Exactly, Sister Act Two.
- Dark Knight.
- It's easy to be weirded
out by the other flavors
but I think they pretty yummy.
- You heard it there first.
- Pretty yummy.